and never look
backs and simply learn to get ahead jish
a civil engineer turned data scientist
who decided to Simply learn
possible with a course from a premier
[Music]
University true champion who upskilled
to win big how big a massive hike that
transformed my life Danish Chang gears
pretty early in the race but pron wanted
to explore more to get ahead isar simply
learn from mechanical engineering to a
data analyst and a podcaster in his free
time transformation simply learn
industry
expert data
expert with a well structured Co course
it felt like a piece of cake that is
simply awesome what's also awesome is
that long didn't choose a quick fix he
just added data science into the
mix nithan how did you change the game
worked on real industry problems to
become the real deal a joint family a
regular job responsibilities but nothing
could stop nin from getting ahead what
an allrounder day ho night with flexible
learning you can always make it right
passion
situation
you too will find your way to get ahead
when you simply
learn simply learn get ahead with simply
[Music]
Lear recording in
progress
[Music]
for
hello everyone uh once again welcome
welcome fantastic to have you all on
board so I am Rasha Khan and I'm joining
from all the way from Bangalore India
would love to know where you're joining
from meanwhile I saw that introductions
already started coming in so that's
great uh would love to know where you're
joining us
from so let the global conversation
begin before we start we'll be starting
in few
minutes meanwhile let me just take you
through the ground rules here so we have
few quick easy ground rules here so in
case you have any questions for our
speaker who's already joined the St of
you can put down your questions in the
Q&A box and the session is being
recorded so in case you want to go
through the session recording once again
in case you miss something out you can
expect a followup email with the
recording link the webinar certificate
and also the bonus offer for attending
the session for the program part which
will talking about you know in the
upcoming slides and also to request a
proof of attendance for this webinar you
can enter your name in the post webinar
survey so that is something if you have
any questions about the post webinar
survey I'll be taking it towards the end
and also for the webinar certificate you
need to stay till the end of the session
in order to get the webinar certificate
so I hope that makes it all clear uh and
uh about the agenda of the session so uh
we'll be starting to getting to know a
little bit more about you how we can
help you out better in your career in
full stack development and uh much more
about you and taking up questions from
you helping you out uh and addressing
all of your queries as much as possible
and uh and we'll be talking about full
St web development careers and after
that we'll be talking about the calex
full stack program what this program
exactly offers and how this program gets
your job ready and also taking you
through the enrollment steps and there
will be special duration for the Q&A
part so in case in case you have
questions obviously are here because you
are interested in fullstack development
and want to know a little bit more about
uh the career in fullstack development
so in case you have any questions
related to that or program in general
you can let us know in the Q&A box so
just to help you navigate okay uh the
Q&A box is just beside the chat box
right now we are having a amazing
conversation I can see folks basically
have introduced themselves here I can
see folks have joined from Philippines
India uh and basically I can see someone
has joined from UA as well uh and uh I
can see more introductions coming in on
chart here so awesome okay okay I I'll
go go slow so fine so uh let's before we
start the session as I mentioned that we
let's get to know each other a little
better so there's a quick poll on your
screen here so we would love to know how
many years of experience do you
currently have so let's get to know
right what all folks have joined here
and basically what experience uh set you
know they come from so you can see four
quick options here the first one being
less than two years second one 2 to 5
years third one 6 to 10 years and the
last one more than 10 years so please
choose the most suitable option for you
here and uh in case it does not cover
the number of years of experience do you
have you can let us know in chat here as
well so it's okay I'll just give like 10
seconds more for the poll here uh before
we start and we already have our speaker
here with us
ragavendra and uh we'll be basically uh
starting the session just once we done
with this poll so I see a lot of active
set of folks here and uh while I was
speaking I can see the polls moving in
so that's
great uh but but I for only for a few
people who have still not shared the
responses over the poll here I'll just
give like 5 Seconds more uh before we
move on to the introduction part of our
speaker here rindu is already here with
us uh before we start so meanwhile
ravindu where are you joining even I'm
joining from Bangalore even I'm of
Bangalore oh
awesome awesome awesome awesome uh okay
I think we've gotten everyone has
already shared responses for this poll
here so I'll just quickly end this poll
in 5 seconds so 5 4 3 2 1 let me quickly
end the poll and share the results with
you folks as well so Raab let's see like
we can see that 76% of the folks who
have joined us have less than two years
of experience and 18% folks have two to
five years of experience and few of them
have six to 10 years of experience so
we've gotten a you know complete set of
audience here who basically come from
different different set of experiences
so again like thank you so much folks
for sharing that with us and uh
again like I think uh questions have
started coming in on the Q&A Bo so
that's great uh I see I see that folks
have come prepared with their questions
here we'll we'll try to take as many
questions as possible maybe throughout
the session uh but don't worry about it
we'll try to address all of your queries
towards the end so uh like please have
some patience with us and yes as I said
that first again like would like to
welcome ragav indria to the session
first of thank you for taking the time
out for this career master class and
of and welcome again like would you like
to give us your introduction rabindra to
theow yeah yeah so myself rindra like
all of you guys know so I working one of
the forun leared companies so I can't
really reveal the name so I I I lead a
team of 12 members and I also do a lot
of sessions like this across various
platforms like not just this I you can
say upgrad learning uh Newton School
urea all these places actually I teach
uh these sessions and also whenever I'm
free fre I take sessions on weekends on
week days like this one hour webinars I
take this I come with total 10 years
experience in that majorly I have
experience on full development only
wherein I worked in mean stack M Stack
Java with full stack spring spring boot
Technologies all these things I worked
in the past 10 years and also U I have
made sure many students succeed in their
careers with the kind of teaching what
simply learn also provided like that's
one of the very good platform where I
also train and I take regular classes
I'm also one of the instructors in them
as well yeah that's the very brief
introduction about me thank you thank
you so much ravindra for the
introduction again like welcome once
again uh I think we start with uh about
careers in fullstack development uh so
starting with uh fullstack development
how it has become like you know one of
the most hot you know jobs right now and
uh how does it basically the web gets
built by fullstack development can you
tell us a little bit more about that
okay so basically full stack development
is not U like first of all before I
speak about this I want to tell you guys
this word fullstar development only
coined very recently it was not there
when I started my career uh back maybe
10 years ago it was just the front end
and the back end so it was there was
nothing called Full stack so I used to I
joined as a backend developer knowing
JavaScript was just an advantage in the
company wherever you work for as time
progressed I think maybe 20134 I guess
where it picked up lot of pace in it and
by the time 2017 come it was
full-fledged on every company was hiring
for for this full stack guys the reason
be be being behind Hing this is just to
reduce the workforce and get work from
one person developer with multiple roles
as it like let's say if I'm running a
startup I don't want to hire multiple
developers one developer knows both the
things will be sufficient for me so
that's how this full stack development
came came into the picture and that is
the evolution of full development I feel
and this is purely on based on my
knowledge on my experience now what is
full start development is it's just the
front end back end as well as databases
we have in the when I say front end we
speak about again there is SL one more
coming up technology what involves here
so here whatever we see look and feel
like what the buttons the pages the tabs
the menus all these things whatever you
see those are consist of your U why and
nowadays we have Frameworks for
everything to build upon we have
Frameworks for JavaScript we have
Frameworks for CSS we have Frameworks
for back end also okay that consist of
the front end now we go to back end
where the Whenever I send a click let's
say I click on something to load up the
table the data comes in and sits there
right how it sits it's just on the click
on that we have a we send AR rest and
there will be L endpoint exposed from
back end or maybe a Java endpoint maybe
a spring uh like controller endpoint or
maybe a node Endo or Express endpoint
whatever so that will be listening for
your front end whenever make such
request it just sends back the response
and that's what the back end is it just
mainly helps you to answer all the
queries whatever your UI asks for and it
sends in a specific format called as
Json where they both communicate it
doesn't matter what back end is written
on it just expects the right response
that's the that's the beauty of your
separation of concerns I have front end
written in some language a I have
backend some language B I don't need to
know what language the a is written on I
just need to just say I want this the
request back like back to the UI I just
do that request I get the response back
and that is the beauty of Again full
full development and the backend
Technologies can be Java node python R
go Etc there are many okay it's endless
but these are the very famous
Technologies currently in the market and
now coming to the database now database
we have no SQL and SQL database when I
speak SQL we have rdbms we have
Oracle SQL and these are the very famous
databases we have many and no SQL
currently in the market and trending you
would say mongodb you have Cassandra etc
etc so these two databases scatter for
this back end which uses for persistent
persistent layer so this three layer
consist of full stack development and
that's what makes it special this is not
one directional it is
multi-directional yeah that's about
FSD uh that sounds pretty interesting to
me a career in full stack development I
think we'll talk more about the careers
right in the next slide so uh as we can
see that there are so many career paths
you can take up you know in full stack
development but when basically if
someone thinks about full stack
development they only think of becoming
a full stack developer right that is
what comes to mind but there are so many
other career paths can take up as we can
see on our screen here and can you tell
us a little bit about these career paths
and uh maybe we'll take a questions
related to the career PA you know later
on we're getting those questions in the
Q&A box but yeah to start with yeah see
basically one advantage of learning full
stack is let's say I learned I took a
course and simply learn and learned the
full development okay after that you are
equipped with multiple knowledge okay
you are you know the frontend technology
for example angular you know the backend
technology for example Java spring now
you also know one database maybe Oracle
or SQL so now you can explore your
career in multiple phases you can be a
full developer like what you already
made the course that consist of this
entire N2 technology and let's say for
some reason you are not comfortable in
the front end then you can become purely
a backend developer okay and that also
has a good very very good
like demand in market and let's say now
my like interest is in just the UI I am
very comfortable building UI I don't
want touch back end you can also explore
equally with equally paying jobs in
Market with just becoming front-end web
developer also now there is one more
specialization not just this you have
one more role called as UI developer
this developers what they do is they
don't focus on lot of UI writing they
only focus on look and feel of the
entire UI
for that is also very very popular in
market now you you might have saw if you
scroll LinkedIn you see is this UI
better this UI better you get those
three buttons better or three like menu
are better which one is better that
question comes in you know why they ask
that question they want to understand
what a end user thinks of it that's what
the responsibility of U developer UI on
duux developer they do a lot of research
on just about look and feel that is one
more area where you can explore your
expertise and you can also become uh
like Architects that only for the like
experienced folks initially maybe till
six years seven years it will not be
relevant for you but again if you are
experienced person this would be very
much relevant for you you can become
architect and let's say no none of these
are interested now you're very
comfortable in the database you can also
become DBA developer also where you are
you can write SQL queries and you can
write store procedures all these things
okay these are multiple roles every
single point I told you front end back
end and database individually can
explore and become engineer in engineer
like in that particular stream and also
if you took take one elective here we
have Cloud you can also become Cloud
engineer look at the beauty of learning
this one course and you have so many
options to explore that that's the
beauty of this course here yeah oh well
that's very interesting that not just
one career path you can take so many
career paths here and again like thank
you so much for taking us through that
as we been talking about skills as well
right the skills which actually open up
these career paths right where you can
uh see so many skills here basically
which uh a full stack web work can
basically learn uh basically and what
basically comes in the job requirement
as well you know when you apply for
those job uh maybe can you tell us a
little bit about the skills as well you
know okay I like I mentioned I
segregated into three portions now let's
take one by one and I will pinpoint you
what that technology it like what that
uh side it consist of now if you say
front end if you want to excel in the
front end you need to First Excel
yourself in static markup language and
that is your HTML you build the HTML
your like backbone is ready now you need
to make it look good how with the help
of CSS you have CSS 3 standard in the
the market and not just very plain CSS
you have your framework as of now in the
market there are lots of framework very
famous one is bootstrap and if you go
for angular you have you have one
framework for that if you go for re you
have one framework for that every UI
like the technology whatever theyve
exposed they are exposing one extra
framework from their side to make their
technology to look good for angular they
are again have their own inhouse
framework for your CSS because that is
more compatible for the UI what they
provide even for react also okay that is
these are the UI Technologies which are
famous now if you go to angular angular
is not just a library it's a complete
framework why I say that because it
provides so many additional features
bundled by default the moment you
install you are good to go for example
routers you have maybe it's too early to
speak about all those things but the
framework is as of today it's so much
capable the moment you install you you
can do a lot of things which other like
like if you go to react you need to
maybe install all those things one by
one that's the reason simply learn
chooses angular over react to build this
UI for this in this fullstar development
course and that's on the front end now I
come to the middle layer in this we have
Java when I say
Java like we definitely will learn about
the core Java in the core Java we learn
about all the basics of core Java then
then we move on to the advanced Java
that's where you your framework comes
into picture there you learn about this
what is the very important point is
servlets okay we all know spring boot
okay it's one of the buzz word in the
market where everyone uses but what is
used behind spring boot none of us
really bothered to know and that's what
spring boot internally uses these
servlets you can ask why are we using
that like why are we learning that many
people doesn't even understand how
things works in the behind the scenes
they just learn cream layer and go
across
the intention of putting such Concepts
in this curriculum is to make sure you
guys know from the depth what you have
learning first we make sure you learn
Java then we'll introduce you to suets
then we'll introduce you to like
Advanced jsps and suets and then we'll
go to Spring and after that we introduce
spring boot look at the layering one by
one by one to make sure you understand
every step clearly by the end of this
course you'll be in the back end section
I'm telling you'll be so much sure about
what you're learning every step and then
the communication part as I spoken right
soap and soap and Dr these are the and
like these are the frame which which
which will help you to expose your end
points which your front end communicates
with okay and that's what the
communication channel here now if I move
on to hibernates this is again database
agnostic framework which helps us to
communicate from the Java layer or the
back layer to the database side now I
have tables ready I need to pick them
now let's say my database written in a
SQL Cassandra doesn't matter you
need to tell iberet iberet my database
is XY Z and provide some configuration
that's it the heav lifting is done by
hibernates it makes sure it picks the
data converts it into a proper Jon
format and sends it back to the UI and
that whole communication is seamless
that's the that's what the technology
IET provides us also jba does one level
ahead of that okay and JavaScript is
again I told you the core for your react
es6 is a standard which is used across
the market now we have one more level
es7 so what is es means ecas script 6
earlier days we used to have ecas script
5 ecmascript 4 people might not know
because es6 only people remember because
this is where lot of new features got
introduced and that's why es6 is famous
and JavaScript es6 is one of the famous
like the jarons going around these are
the Technologies you will be learning in
this course as you go
across oh well that sounds a lot of
skills you know you'll be covering in
this program uh but ragab just one
question I'm pretty sure the crowd wants
to know this uh there's always this
dilemma right where do you get started
like someone who want wants to get
started what would you them to get
started
with okay so basically if you uh like I
if I I also I'm also instructor here
what you do is we will start go in such
a way that first we'll make sure you
know about DSA okay for any interview
for it may be a fresher or 10 year
experienced guy interviews clearing is
one of the very important aspect that's
why we all join here let's be practical
now for that we also keep in mind that
that aspect also and we will make sure
we train you in uh DSA data structures
and algorithm in that you become well
versed that should be the first point
any developer who wants to become
developer in their uh like career that
is the first step get some good Hands-On
on problem solving get your hands dirty
there spend some good amount of time
there that's what we tell you to do and
we also provide you training on that
then we'll move on to the core Java
Basics okay so uh I I have the entire
curriculum step wise I discuss that but
in the before I'll just give you a
glimpse so then you'll go on to the Java
then after that we learn about we we
learn about one more level ahead we
learn the Frameworks of java okay then
we'll move on to the back end sorry the
front end first we finish the back end
because we learned DSA just now Java if
we finished we finished about the
Frameworks also then we'll move on to
the J HTML CSS then bootstrap then we'll
go to angular and then we'll write the
communication between your front end and
back end now this is just level one next
we'll move on to level two that is your
spring boot level that means Advanced
spring Advanced Javas Java Concepts
where we come tell you whatever heavy
lifting you have done in your code by
yourself now will be done by framework
your subet jsps are written to make sure
you write all The Code by yourself but
now now that heavy lifting is done by
framework and we show you this is what
the heavy lifting is by framework and
that is very useful for you guys okay
now you go learn about your Advanced
spring Concepts then we'll go on learn
about your devops and database Concepts
okay now I will uh let me know one when
I can share my screen and I can show all
these things to them sure sure sure let
me just uh also check the access yeah
you free to share okay
cool is my screen visible to all of you
guys
yeah it's visible to me uh folks please
do let this know in chat here by just
replying yes or
no awesome awesome visible I think we
getting responses in the chat okay cool
so I have created this text P just for
the quick uh like instead of going to
the website and all this is easy for me
and for you guys also to understand as
you can see here these are the multiple
phases we go through in the first phase
we have this uh lvc we will introduce
you agile what is agile I missed out in
that technology thing agile is a
standard methodology where we do
development in phases okay earlier days
what used to happen we used to do
development for six continuous months
and then we go for
stakeholders by this what actually
happens is let us say some mistakes I
did in the initial month only let's say
first month second month I did not know
I continued to build on top of the
mistake and entire
development is completed sixth month I
went to stakeholders I demoed them they
like what is this what you have built
you made a very basic mistake in the
initial level only then they will change
the change the things and will come back
and repeat everything for next four
months that is what fall model we call
it as and that way of development was
followed 10 years ago when I joined IT
industry it was just about to get like
wrapped up and then comes agile what
this is here what we do we have Sprints
there are a lot of terminologies here
guys I work in a very strict in my
company also but there are a lot of
terminologies I will not going go into
that detail I will tell you very basics
of it what this will do is every three
weeks two weeks or four weeks we divide
into Sprints now what we do we do the
work for three weeks we demo it to the
stakeholders hey this is what we
developed are we aligned to the end goal
what do you think of it do you recommend
some changes if if they say yes we
incorporate if they say no very good we
continue again next 3 weeks we Implement
some more things on top of it we'll come
back to the stakeholders hey what do you
think now are we in the right path they
say yes we will if they say yes we will
take it if there will be some feedback
we will take it and we will consider it
we will change then and there only we
will not wait till the end point like
this every phased man development
happens at the end even stakeholder is
happy and stakeholder is confident now
what's happening in the team is align to
my expectations so this is one of the
advantage of agile and that is your
first Topic in this entire course and
then git what is git git is a source
Version Control we call SVC what this is
used for let us say we as a team working
for one project we are 10 members in the
team now I am working on component one
one my team member is working component
to etc etc and entire team is working on
multiple components now after every
component wrapping up I need to push it
to some place right we call it as source
code repository we will push all the
changes and also pull all the changes
from them that means it is if I tell you
simple words collaboratively work within
the team with sharing the code of each
other this is what we use git for in
multiple companies multiple softwares
they use it but the ultimate goal is the
same okay to make sure you work as a
team
collaboratively sharing your code and
getting the other developers code
together that's it and then in this
particular thing what we do is we do
Java Deep dive we'll talk about building
blocks of java then we'll speak about
interfaces Collections and then these
are the three introduction you can ask
me you told DSA first why are we
speaking about Java here let's say I am
from a non Tech background I don't know
what is abcf coding how can I learn DSA
I'll not be able to write that is the
reason we will educate you first how
what is Java Basics then we will get
your get your hands dirty on DSA here
we'll make sure we'll teach you guys
about arrays lists and we also learn
about sorting searching and also we
learn about some more DSA skills which I
can't mention everything here that's I
just mentioned about two pointer here
and very important now I learned all
these things I will be doing one project
phase end project at every end of the
face okay to make sure is my
understanding are aligned to the course
so you will also understand whatever
you've done till now you do a project
and you're good with it that is about
the phase one next you have phase two
here what we do we learn about Java web
pages and DB management here we build we
use Ser Leets we use jdbc also we use
iberet all
these just about initial I would say not
the the complete framework Advanced
framework just initial framework we
learn where core Frameworks seret JSP or
core Frameworks which is built on top of
java okay level one here also we do one
phase in Project next we go on to the
next level that is spring MVC and
advanced Java programming I told you
this point only we will use spring
framework plus spring boot framework
plus
microservices okay we you might have
heard like nowadays if you if you open
flip cart or Amazon how you know those
things work you have a card page that is
one micros service products page one
microservice you have uh like mobiles
page one microservice every small small
modules micros service they communicate
within each other with the help of such
small frame spring boot applications
that's the beauty of this microservices
so they help us to communicate between
the different services and we'll be
learning about that here like I told you
we will be doing a project also here at
the end of this particular phase this
this is about spring MVC sorry the
advanced Java programming phase now we
learn
about creating Rich front end what is
this here I don't just follow this I
will make sure you learn about HTML CSS
then I will come to this particular
portion called as Bo strap
we will learn this completely thoroughly
and then I will make make sure you learn
about JavaScript extremely important
without this your journey of angular
will be incomplete or you will not be
able to code also just like your spring
boot requires Java knowledge your
angular requires JavaScript knowledge
mandatorily so that's the reason I cover
all these things beginning and get
yourself comfortable then we'll move on
to the angular we will build the
entire UI and finally we do one end to
end uh one project in this case what we
do is we will try to communicate to the
other side that means whatever the back
end we built we exposed end points now
we will consume them and display here
maybe a list of movies or I would say
the list of students I'm telling an
example I can't tell you the exact thing
maybe a list of products I want to
display or maybe menu in my uh like
zomato app whatever like that so such
we'll build here and we will do the
communication part and finally we have
this this is actually uh I would say
elective field wherein you can also
learn about more on devox in this pH you
learn about selenium thing I think this
is not the devops yeah yeah this is the
one
yes here you learn about testing your
application how what is E2 what is S3
what is mainly you learn about Cloud
Docker Q kubernetes what what are pods
what are containers how that is used how
do we bring the container up how the
communication happens how can we
segregate uh individual uh like piece in
development and then we do one phase end
project with the help of this particular
thing and this will be elective if you
want to choose you can choose it so
overall all these things you'll be
learning in this course okay now I want
to speak about one course in detail
let's say one phase I will pick this
phase three let's say now if you see in
this if I want to give you a glimpse of
what we do in this phases first we will
learn about what is spring MVC we'll
build a entire uh framework we will
build the entire framework with from the
core we understand how to communicate to
database we also make sure how to expose
an endo and also some event handling
we'll do all these things in the lesson
one and next we'll move to lesson two
here we expose restful end points we
learn about EX handling of spring boot
what difference between spring Boot and
spring we have also file handling how
can we do that what is Swagger very
important what is Apache Kafka how this
Q Works what are Q's uh what are M Q's
messaging qes how to make sure your
application is uh secure by learning
https all these things we learn about
this listen to and then finally we'll
come on to junit testing this is
extremely important why because I return
return the entire framework code now in
this entire framework code how can I
make sure my end points are functional I
need to make sure as a developer write
and this is the way to confirm I write
those junit cases to make sure my
endpoints are returning successful
results how can how can I validate I
pass some dummy input I expect the
output the way I pass input as let us
say from the UI I anticipate this a
input I want B output I always make sure
write that unit test cases which
actually test checks both the things you
know that is what this lesson three all
about we write the entire junit cases
there are multiple things in junit cases
I will show all all of them in detail
and then finally we'll move on to uh
this web services here this is
completely on Spring boot also micro
Services what I mentioned here if you
see here this is microservices in this
case I will talk about creating multiple
such small spring applications and way
to communicate between them so all these
things we be discussing in detail in
this particular phase three okay so this
is what I've given you a bird view in a
in a way detailed bird view what we're
going to do in this entire phase so
because I an instructor here I know each
and every line here that's why I'm
telling you with so much confidence you
will learn all these things in this
entire
course yeah uh I'm done from my side
Rasha you can take it from yeah sure uh
let me just quickly share back my screen
folks and also ravinda that was you know
so interesting thank you for Sing us to
the environment basically you know what
exactly do we cover a little bit sneak
peek into it and uh also uh I think we
have talked about the skills here uh we
have talked about what career paths you
know folks can take up taking up uh this
program in full St development so we
want to understand what exactly is the
biggest challenge here when it comes to
becoming a full stack developer you're
here because you're interested in this
field right uh so we actually would want
to know what is the biggest challenge
here what's stopping you from becoming a
full developer so the poll which you see
on your screen here right now uh this is
a multiple choice P so uh you can
actually select multiple options here
because they can be multiple concerns
right uh so I'll just read out those
options for you while I was speaking
folks have already started sharing uh
the responses so that's great we've
gotten really active audience here so
I'll just read out those options for you
so what exactly is stop help in you from
becoming a fullstack deliver so the
first one I can't find a program with a
fully comprehensive curriculum the
second one I don't have the Practical
exposure I need to become job ready the
third one I find it difficult to learn
from pre-recorded videos and the last
one my work schedule won allow me enough
fful learning so as I was speaking I can
see folks have already started their
concern basically uh you know in terms
of aspiring a career in fullstack
development so uh I think I'll just give
10 seconds more because I can see most
of the folks are already Shar the
responses that's great uh so for other
folks who are still thinking about it in
case this PO does not cover your concern
can let us know on the chat or Q&A box
as well and meanwhile ra while you were
speaking taking us through you know the
sneak peek into the program here
basically what do we cover we actually
are getting very interesting questions
in the Q&A box as well which will be
taking in some time folks uh so thank
you so much for interesting questions
here I can see I'm scrolling through the
questions here uh and yeah I think I'll
just give five seconds move for the poll
here basically what is the biggest
challenge here when it comes to becoming
a full stack
developer so five four 3 2 1 let me
quickly end the poll and also sh share
the results with you
folks okay uh as we can see Raab here
the we have gotten the highest amount of
votes 52% for I wouldn't get the
Practical exposure I need to become job
ready and 42% of the folks have voted
for I can't find the program with a
fully comprehensive curriculum and I can
see few of the fors for I find it
difficult to learn from pre-recorded
videos and my work schedule won allow me
in effectful learning so again like
thank you so much for sharing your
biggest concern here now moving to the
program preview here uh so the calex pro
program in fullstack development comes
with a comprehensive curriculum and
Industry online learning part uh the you
get to work on integrated key studies
and Hands-On projects for prac
experience which will be talking little
bit about in the upcoming slides but
ragav ragab has mentioned you know like
the projects basically you know step by
step we'll be getting to work on you
know these projects you know and we'll
be talking more about those projects in
the upcoming slides and online virtual
classroom with peer and instructor
interaction and flexible to fit your
lifestyle and schedule in case you are
working professional and you have other
responsibilities this program is like
you know manageable to basically
complete in 10 to 15 hours per week of
bandwidth and the program duration for
someone I think someone asked that the
q& box is 9 months so you can just
complete this by giving 10 to 15 hours
per week I do have a question for you ra
uh that how does the live virtual
classroom look like in this program you
know when folks take up this program by
Caltech they have expectations right so
what is the peer and instructor
interaction looks like is it like boring
or like is it like some interesting you
know crowd to be a part of like can you
tell us a little bit about that when in
see first of all multiple different
institutes do a different way okay what
I like about this this project is they
will ask us to do in the class okay and
we will I will be more interactive and I
will be going along with the students so
that's the beauty of it you know so from
the beginning till the end I will make
sure you are with me I will go on
certain pace which is suitable for most
of the students okay so that they always
follow me at till the end and I'll make
sure it's completed and I will keep an
tab on whatever doubts they have let's
say in the class it's not clear okay I
also Mis wrote one more point when I was
teaching you this so let's say after
sessions session generally will be on
Saturday Sundays uh like 4 hours in the
evening or the I mean I'm not sure about
the time zone in the US but 4 hours on
Saturday Sunday let's say after that
sessions session is over should we wait
for next week to come to talk to me
answer is absolutely no what we do is at
the end of every session we'll be
providing you a GitHub link wherein all
my code will be pushed second thing will
be providing you
the Google Drive Link wherein if I have
a big big image or big files I'll be
putting in that documentation anything
and also third one very important one we
will be providing you Community Link
wherein interesting you need to post
your question and not just me anyone
office or any instructors any yourp will
get in touch with you and make sure you
are unblocked as soon as possible you
don't need to wait till the next week to
come like talk to me again so that is a
very beneficial Advantage when you take
the course here so you are always like
we'll be keep a tab on you how are you
progressing in your
course wow that's that's sounds like a
pretty interesting environment to be a
part of you know when you're learning
and you're taking up this postgrad
program and post I think we have few
questions about the program the fee and
the you know schedule I'll be sharing
that meanwhile uh what exactly you'll be
get from getting from this program so
you'll be getting a CTIC ctme full stack
web certificate here you can see on your
screen here and you'll be getting
Hands-On and projects and integrated
labs to work on which we have mentioned
earlier we'll be talking more about it
you'll be receiving up to 25 CS from
calch ctm that is equivalent to 250
hours of you learning so that's pretty
great and I think rabindra already
mentioned that CTIC ctm Circle
membership so you get to be a part of
these you know Learners who come from
different different uh diverse sort of
Industries which be talking about you
know more in the upcoming slides and
career assess services and uh online
convocation as well so the online
convocation I find the most interesting
uh part of this program here that uh in
an offline setting you get to invite
maybe your family closest family or like
very close friends here you can
basically invite your family closest
friends uh far relatives you know
friends who are basically in different
parts of the world or states and they
get to basically see you getting this
convocation online so that is again like
one of the most interesting Parts here
from CeX CDM
uh about the eligibility and sites here
so uh all you need to have is a
bachelor's degree with an average of 50%
or higher marks and uh basically you
need to have a basic programming
knowledge of and also basically you need
to have at least two plus years of work
experience is preferred it is not
compulsory but preferred so like I just
have a question I'm pretty sure the
crowd also wants to know basic
programming knowledge so uh have you
seen students succeed if basically they
have some sort of basic programming
knowledge and when they take up this
program to become a fullstar web
developer can you tell us a little bit
about
that uh I didn't completely get get you
can you sure sure I was saying that uh
as as we can see that for the
eligibility for this program is like you
know you need to have a basic
programming knowledge so I wanted to
know that have you seen students succeed
who basically have like very basic
program because this is a full we
development program right yes yes
absolutely so guys this is this course
is not one month two month course okay
the course spans at least like four to
six months okay a person who doesn't
even know ABC of coding can still be a
good developer in my batch only I've
seen people who getting plays in very
good companies okay not one out of many
okay why I'm telling you this because
they don't even know anything that's the
reason I start from the very beginning
of the coding I make sure you guys know
Java first because to know that DSA Java
is important we feel everyone same we by
default assume you guys know nothing
because it would be great for us to
teach in a better way like that if I
assume that you guys know something on
coming year will not help me okay I
generally I do this I assume that you go
go nothing I have to educate everything
like that I take up and I always make
sure that everyone in the same page and
I will make sure that you learn about
Java Basics then you go for next Java
next DS say after that your like
Advanced framework comes in that's how I
go forward so answer is yes you can
Excel but only one thing is important
your dedication and perseverance about
whatever I tell you to do at the end of
the day you guys must should do that
okay this is very important guys this is
the like the like ground rules for this
entire
course I I totally agree dedication is
equally important uh as you basically
you know take up these skills to learn
and projects to work on and acquire
these skills in this program uh thank
you so much for answering that now
moving on how this program basically
prepares you uh and gets your job ready
so as we can see on the screen here uh
so how the program builds your
development skills step by step right
can you take us through these steps for
the crowd to understand you know what
basically will be happening in this
program step by step I think exact same
thing I explained when I shared my
screen ex exactly exactly it's it's all
the step by step you have this
introduction then you learn the planning
and D design then you learn about the
back end and database design development
sorry and then you talk about API end
points finally integration and
development you do that is devops and
you do one caption project I again
missed out on this this involves
whatever you learned in all the faces
you put together and make one piece by
that you learn end to end and that's
what this entire ladder you are seeing
here and that is very important and very
useful definitely
yeah uh again like I you have taken
through these steps like in much more
detail before before you know we even
came to this slide I think I just
mention about the electives which we
have met that you get access to calch
ctma full stack development master
classes and uh you also get generative
AI master classes as well as in part of
the elective uh so you don't have to pay
anything extra for that this comes as a
part of the program uh so it's optional
it is up to you if you want to take it
up so moving on uh to the master in
demand tools libraries and platforms you
get to cover in this program uh so as we
can see on the screen there are so many
tools and libraries and platforms here
but obviously there are much more than
this what we cover ra can maybe can you
take us through these tool seies and
platforms and give folks a little bit a
better idea what you know we are seeing
on the screen here yes yes yes so I I
told you in very plain and text
languages now you're seeing images here
yeah spoke angular definitely we learn
about angular G I spoke you have a g
here Jenkins is a way to do devops it is
continuous development continuous
integration cicd we call it as okay then
you have mongod DV it's your database
you have Maven it is mainly to like LP
your genkins all those like building the
projects and everything we have CSS
rabit mq for communication junit is for
test unit test cases my equals database
again typescript typescript is your
Advanced transfered JavaScript language
we will be learning all these things in
the entire part part of the course so
these are your tools which you'll learn
after the end of the like by the end of
this particular
course well that sounds pretty
interesting a lot of tools iies to cover
in this particular course thank you so
much for taking us through that now
moving on uh we mentioned about the cap
project right so the cap projects you
can showcase to your future employeers
here they give you that true experience
you can Showcase in your portfolio uh
for someone who's coming from a non
coding or non webstar background uh I
just have one question uh for this
particular cap project here so how does
a caption project having that on your
portfolio resume when you're trying to
get out there when you're done with the
program here right you're trying to get
out there and land your dream job in
full stack how does it help how does it
help for someone who does has not no
experience in this yes now let's say I
I'm coming with abolute experience right
so you if you done the project if you go
for an interview they'll ask you can you
show us project whatever you have done
you can just share your GitHub and tell
this is my project and if they ask you
you should be able to explain everything
and that is what the very good part
about this by doing capston project they
will easily able to judge how much of
you know by this entire course whatever
you learned it will it just shows your
confidence and it'll show your like
whatever skill set you have and that's
where capson projects plays a very vital
role in your
interviews thank you so much for
answering that that makes sense like for
someone coming from a completely coding
or you know non background uh now moving
on uh so the past Learners and their
success stories I think I've asked you
about it a little bit about you know how
does it look like do they succeed if
they come from a a very basic
programming background and they have
very basic knowledge so about the
Learners here so the classes include
Learners from excellent organizations
and diverse Industries uh Industries
like software product information
technology bfsi telecomunication others
and also the companies Amazon Microsoft
e Del deloid IBM Oracle B and many more
I think we are not able to cover in the
slide that's why you can see only these
many companies here so Learners you'll
be basically joining this program with
will be very uh interesting coming from
different backgrounds and diverse
Industries so that is something very
interesting now talking about the
Learners here so we have few learner
success stories here as we can see that
Vidya basically has shared that you know
her learning experience was great and
she's thankful to the team for providing
upskilling opportunities and got placed
in a reputable organization and also
about Raj grp group here as we can see
uh basically has shared that love the
format and Logistics so much that I
would love to enroll in more courses by
simply learn so that's that's pretty
great sopnil here basically assistance
engineer in uh Delhi so has basically
shared that he switched his job to TCS
uh as a Java developer and now is
working as systems engineer and also has
gotten a 20% salary hike as well I I
don't think so that's bad I think that's
pretty good and Puja Chri here basically
says that you know this basically
program is pretty highly beneficial and
has helped her Hub skill and since she
was a fresher here uh she's glad that
she got her first job offer letter you
know after completing this scho so
that's these are the learner SE and many
thousands of it you know which obviously
we cannot put here but I'll be sharing
the link of the program here for for you
to check out later uh so here we talked
about basically the skills the projects
the career paths you can take up we have
shared the learner success stories here
we have to you through the program flow
here as well I think maybe rabindra we
can take like few questions here as we
have promised them we will take few
questions you know before we move on
midle of the program yes so sure I think
let's browse to the questions here yeah
sure so one person asked me the question
besides front end front end and other
framework software are the only for this
question uh I have explained you the all
three divisions they ask very initial
time only I think that is answered you
will be learning about your front end
your back end database these three
layers I also explained in detail about
what technologies we will learning in
this and everything I'll take it as
answer
uh and next person is asking me the
question saying that how
will FSD I explained this
also okay what whether full development
of future guys yes definitely yes FSD
have future okay I'll not tell you very
bastic at least next 15 20 years you
have bright future but text stack may
change but full stack idea will remain
okay that's it so that's about uh one
question which one is the best among
backend and front developer guys I'm a
full stack guy I love both front end and
back back end equally if you learn more
about problem solving and like
complicated things then you may like
back end if you learn more about like
designing structuring you may like UI so
again I I leave it to your choice to
choose one so I like both as web
developer you advise me to continue PHP
using Frameworks guys PHP laravel all
these are old Frameworks okay so maybe
you can learn python also is good again
for that also we have courses but in
this effect D we mainly focus on Java
and that's what like mainly we use also
so to this question I would not
recommend you to continue on a
Technologies please upgrade yourself and
learn right like Technologies whatever
we are recommending you which is
definitely future
proof and then does this program have
any connection with blockchain
development answer is no this is no way
link to blockchain at all okay but good
question uh upgrade as self-based course
uh would it be helpful okay guys
self-based course I'm not very sure so
about that particular thing I'll only
stick on to the simply Larn course
whatever they have they have very nice
course here there is nothing selfed
everything is instructor driven that's
the beauty of it you don't need you
won't get much recordings you everything
is instructor driven here exactly and
also like a lifetime access of the B
Bally the classes as well right so
that's again another plus here so I
think thank you so much agab for taking
few questions you know as we promised
them uh so moving on so we have talked
about the skills here we have talked
about the career paths you can take up
in fullstack web development and we have
talked about projects you can work on so
you can see a quick poll question on the
screen here would you like to enroll
into the CTIC postgraduate program in
full stack uh also just to remind you
there's a bonus offer for attending this
webinar we don't do this we do this very
rarely here so uh for this program for
attending this webinar we getting giving
a bonus offer as well so that you can
Avail uh in basically uh more than six
months from now and I'll be asking you
that question as well you know when do
you plan to enroll so we can understand
when basically you want want to start it
just an assumption of it but as I was
speaking I can see a lot of interest
like coming towards enrollment so that's
great uh keep that coming in meanwhile
uh we will just give it like 15 seconds
for folks who are still thinking about
it and also about the cohort here we
take only like some 25 to 30 folks for
coh in order to make sure that they are
getting all the attention that is
required here when they're taking up
this CTIC ctm postgraduate program in
full well development and also uh the
cap project you know which you get to
work on in this through this program
that basically helps you get job ready
get out the get out there and get a job
of your dreams in full stack web
development which is a very hard career
choice right now so I think U as I was
speaking I can see the enrollment part
part of the program like moving up in
the pole but that's great I can see
folks have a lot of questions here so I
think yeah there are a lot of questions
coming in about the free and where
exactly the next C is starting so I'll
be sharing that in upcoming slides and
also taking you through the enrollment
step so don't worry about that uh so
I'll just give like some 10 seconds more
for the poll here and also while we are
speaking we're getting few more
interesting questions on the Q&A boxes
we'll take that in the Q&A part of the
session which is upcoming next in case
we haven't addressed your query if you
have a question about the program as
well you can let us know uh so
yeah I'll just give 10 seconds more for
folks uh few of the folks who have not
shared the responses for the polia and
uh Meanwhile we're just browsing through
the Q&A box here and I can see rindra is
answering questions as well you know as
we go you can go and check out if you
have basically shared a question uh
related to the program or the career uh
in full stack development in general by
calch here so you can basically check
out he's already answering those
questions for you there addressing them
so as promised we will address as many
queries as possible actually all of them
and we actually are doing that so I
think uh I can see most of the folks
have already shared uh their interest
here in the poll here so I think I'll
just give 10 seconds more and we will
quickly end this poll and move on to the
enr St and the Q&A part so uh so yeah I
think few of the folks who are still
basically thinking about it I would
suggest take up the bonus off there is
so much time to take up the program in
case you are not planning to join it
immediately but the bonus offer is
pretty rare So
Awesome okay I can see most of the folks
have already shared the responses here
so I'll just give five seconds more so 5
4 3 2 1 and I'll quickly end the poll
and thank you so much I saw a lot of
interest towards enrollment so that's
great so let me take you through the
enrollment steps here so the enrollment
steps are very easy three simple steps
here all you need to do is submit your
application uh to us at askers at simply
learn.net also if you have any questions
as well you know you can basically just
drop us a mail there I've shared that
email ID on the chat here in case you
want to check it out uh also the step
two here your application will be going
for review by calex cdme and based on
your qualifications which I've shared
the eligibility earlier uh we will be
basically sharing you the admissions
offer a letter and learning consultant
from C Lear be reaching out to you with
the admissions offer letter so uh that
is about the enrollment steps here uh
now I got a lot of questions about the
program fee and when exactly is the next
C starting for I think for folks have
already shared the interest towards
enrollment so the next welcome session
for this program will be starting on 2nd
of November this year and the cohart
classes will be starting on 9th of
December so there's plenty of time there
you know like to basically uh attend the
induction and start the classes as well
so and the program fee for this one is
uh
99,999 and uh basically sorry
99,999 and this is basically including
taxes and we have financing options
available as well in case you're looking
for Emi options as well you want to pay
it you know uh separately like you know
divide and pay it so the amount for this
is
85542 uh rupees uh per month and we also
have like tution reimbursement
basically which you can ask your
employer about this as well uh and again
as I said that we have very limited CS
you know per per per basically card
which we take and we only take like 25
to 30 CS per card in order to make sure
that we are paying all the attention you
know that is required when you're taking
up this program so uh and also I think
folks might have questions that what is
the program free for my region right so
I think I'll just share that this is for
Indian region folks here but I'll just
share the link towards the program in in
case you want to check it out in much
more detail here so I'll just quickly
share the link here in case you want to
go through the program in much more
detail so moving on so uh folks who have
already shared their interest towards
enrolling which I saw a lot of you folks
so uh we want to know basically how soon
do you plan to enroll so here I'm just
letting you know that in case you are
still thinking about it I would
recommend to select within 3 months
within 6 months within more than 6
months from now because the bonus offer
is something can Avail even more than
six months from now so why to Res on
that right you can basically select
those options and folks I think of the
folks have shared interest basic
basically when is the next you know
upcoming cohort they want to join that
cohort so the first option is the most
suitable for you the immediately one so
I'll just give 10 seconds more as I was
speaking folks have already started
sharing when do they plan to enroll so
that's we've gotten a really active
audience here active set of aspiring
Learners here so that's great and uh and
we have basically answered all of the
questions here on the Q&A box here so we
have very few questions left for the Q&A
part actually like ra is already
answering those questions so I'll just
give five seconds more for the poll here
uh so basically when do you plan to
endroll okay as I can see that most of
the folks have already shared their
responses when do they plan to enroll so
I'll just quickly end the poll in 5
seconds so 5 4 3 two one let me quickly
end the poll and again like thank you so
much for sharing that with us uh so we
have taken most of the questions here
from the Q&A box we actually answered
all of them and we have answered a lot
of them live and answered on the q& Box
in case you have a question uh which we
basically is not answered like you can
check go and check it out on the
answered
box has already answered those so now uh
for folks uh who basically uh have
already shared interest towards
enrollment have also let us know
basically when do you plan to enroll uh
so this is a very quick pool just to
understand if you need assistance uh in
enrolling to the program so I would
suggest like there are two options here
yes or no I would suggest go for the yes
part why not take the extra help right
you're getting the extra help please
take it and understand more about the
program you know from from a learning
Consultants who will help you out take
you through the
program okay someone has asked like if I
can convert the payment yeah I as I
shared there is an Emi option and
basically you can Avail for that
financing Emi option so if you want to
convert the payments into you know fewer
small payments so that is possible
completely I'll just give 10 seconds
more for the poll here uh and I would
like to thank ra first of all you know
for making that effort and answering the
questions all of them actually so while
we were you know going through the
program steps and also taking up all the
questions you know we have gotten for
the program here so thank you so much
for that uh we are actually towards the
end of the program here so uh so Raab
again like once once again like thank
you so much for taking the time out for
taking us through this career master
class on full stack web development and
also taking us to the program as well of
calc ctma so would you like to say
something to the crowd before we
actually end the session definitely guys
one one part I want to mention to all of
you see when I used to when I uh used to
start my career you know there were
nothing like this there were no platform
which is so nice and properly organized
I was cool as when I was learning I used
to struggle everything and learn on my
own maybe made be JavaScript made be
Java spring whatever I did a lot of hard
work and I used to do I didn't know what
the right path also now we have such a
wonderful platform I would recommend you
guys to use it to the fullest and get
your careers like jump kick started as
soon as possible don't wait just enroll
and see where you land actually just
give it a try this you will not regr
reget later I would have taken that when
I when I had an opportunity that regret
should not be there right away go and
enroll and make sure you have a
wonderful career in your going forward
and with that I wish you all the very
best I'll see you on the other side of
the window thank you guys thank you so
much thank you again like thank you like
it was great having you for the session
and I myself feel inspired you know
after attending your session hosting you
so I'm pretty sure folks here let us
know on chat here like how was the
session for you so did you did it give
you a little bit understanding about you
know career in fullstack development so
we'll we'll feel a little better uh for
the upcoming sessions here and also I've
shared with you that we do these uh you
know like helpful career Master Class
you know almost every day throughout the
month and uh basically we would uh you
know you can go and check out uh the
link I've shared with you you know for
the other master classes here in case
you're interested in other cohorts
categories of careers here I want to
explore that as well so again like thank
you so much thank you so much folks for
joining us thank you for being an
amazing uh around here and we hope to
see you in upcoming cohorts uh as for
the number of enrollments I've seen in
the pool here so I think we'll be seeing
a lot of of you and again like once
again thank you so much thank you thank
you we'll be bye- bye bye- bye bye bye
folks see you another session thank you
again once again I
this
[Music]
that